hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the I believe
sixth installment of our daily Q&A
series today's question is how fast can
I cut without unnecessarily increasing
the risk of losing muscle in the process
the reason I phrase it like that
unnecessarily increase the risk is
because when you're cutting there is
always a chance you're going to lose
some muscle in the process it does just
seem that some people naturally hang on
to muscle better when they're cutting
than others do and also plenty of
factors go into this right so are you
still lifting are you eating enough
protein
are you sleeping enough how much you
sleep can impact the ratio of lean mass
to fat mass loss so there's there's a
lot of factors here but essentially the
question I'm answering is above what
rate of weight loss do you dramatically
increase your odds of losing quite a bit
of lean mass when you're cutting so to
answer this question there are two major
factors the first factor is how big you
are and the second is how much body fat
you currently have there was a paper
published in 2005 by a researcher named
Albert and essentially what it set out
to do is see what the upper limit was on
how quickly body fat stores essentially
could liberate fat to be burned and lost
and in that paper the calculated rate
was right around 30 calories per day per
pound of body fat and I saw I think an
interview with the researcher a couple
years after that paper was published
where he said he reran the calculations
and it was more like 22 calories per
pound so I'm just gonna kind of split
the
difference and say about 25 calories per
pound and I'm also doing that because it
makes the math easier you'll see later
so okay
25 calories per pound so you need to
know two things again how big you are
and what your body fat percentage is
that tells you you know how much fat is
on your body and then once you know that
you can know how many calories that fat
can liberate on a per day basis and then
you can calculate a kind of that upper
limit range of weight-loss and so if you
wanted to do all of the steps of the
calculation it would be your body weight
times your body fat percentage times 25
calories per pound times seven days per
week divided by 3500 because there's
roughly 3,500 calories per pound of fat
tissue and then divide that by your
current body weight and that would tell
you the percentage of your body weight
you could lose per week what what you
should aim for is kind of an upper limit
but like I was saying going with 25
calories per pound makes that math much
much easier you can just take your
current body fat percentage and divide
it by 20 just simplifying a bunch of
those steps and that will give you the
percentage of your current body weight
per week that you should lose so body
fat percentage divided by 20 so if
you're 10 percent 10 divided by 20 that
gives you half a percent so you should
shoot to lose about half a percent of
body weight per week so if you're 200
pounds that would be a pound a week if
you're 20 percent body fat then you can
probably shoot to lose about 1 pound per
week so you know if you're 200 pounds 2
pounds per week if you're 30 percent you
can shoot to lose about one and a half
percent of your body weight per week so
if you're 200 pounds three pounds per
week so it's going the the absolute
amount of weight loss that's impacted by
how large you are and then the
percentage of your body weight per week
you're losing is impacted by what your
current body fat percentage is so no
surprise here the more body
yeah.the the higher body fat percentage
you have the faster you can cut
initially so you know if you're 30% one
and a half percent per week down to 10%
half a percent per week so that's going
to impact that and yeah it's it's
largely just based on how quickly her
your fat can can drop fat on a per pound
basis get it into your bloodstream so
you can burn it lose that weight so yeah
really really simple formula there and
again that's that's not taking into
account every single possible scenario
every single possible nuances are
training right are you eating enough
protein is your diet good are you
sleeping enough but just painting in
broad strokes here in general body fat
percentage divided by 20 that is roughly
the percent the percentage of your
current body weight that you can shoot
to lose per week just to make that
calculation nice and easy on you so yeah
and that's that's actually what I'm
using now for my cut obviously I still
have a long way to go but I'm down
almost 25 pounds from where I started
and that that feels pretty good and this
is this is what kind of the the guide
that I've been using for my cut as well
and to this point like I said I
definitely had plenty of fat to lose
when I started still do but my strength
has maintained and actually gone up a
little bit since I started the cut so
even though it has been fairly
aggressive by most standards but it's
it's very very close to kind of the
upper end of the range proposed by this
formula so just in my own experience I
think it works pretty well yeah and it
is just a nifty easy little calculation
you can do for yourself to get an idea
of roughly how fast you can be cutting
without too much risk of losing a bunch
of muscle in the process so that is the
video if you liked it please like and
subscribe and if you have a question
that you won't answer tomorrow
ask it in the comments below and if I
like it I will pick it and that is what
tomorrow's video will cover until then
hope your training is great
hope you have a great day and I will see
you tomorrow